well check this out from
modernhealthcare.com
hhs freezes rule targeting community
health centers and drug discounts
now that title alone probably doesn't
say a whole lot too you're probably like
tim what is this story
this is a story about essentially joe
biden signing an executive order
that reverses trump's rules to reduce
the cost of epipens
and insulin long story short it would
seem that joe biden is trying to make
insulin and epipens more expensive
i'd like to give a round of applause to
all the leftists who want universal
health care and cheap
low-cost goods for your vote for joe
biden which results in the cost of
life-saving medications going up
do you guys remember that story about
the guy who was a minimum wage or
whatever and he couldn't afford insulin
so he was like not buying enough and
then he died he was diabetic and people
were like he needed 30
he tried launching a gofundme to raise
like 30 bucks or 50 bucks
to buy insulin and he couldn't do it
then he died it's a horrifying story man
so sad that was like someone just being
saying please man i just need my
medicine making me think of martin
shkreli but uh yeah the pharmaceutical
rep pharma bro yeah
jack the price up on certain drugs like
7 000 or something i don't remember the
number but there's also another viral
video
showing a young mother crying because
she can't afford the medicine for her
child
and a lot of people are sending this
video being like why isn't this problem
being addressed why is why are medical
costs
so high comparatively to so many other
places in the world
it's insane it's almost criminal in some
ways some of it
some of the arguments are bad some of
the arguments are good like when trump
signed the executive order saying
you in canada you can get insulin and
epipens for dirt but in the u.s the
ridic the price is so high because of
this weird broken system we have
so we signed this executive or i don't
know it's let me read this let me read
this they say
hhs signed off on a rule in december
shortly before uh
donald trump left office it aims to
lower patients out of pocket costs by
forcing community clinics to pass
their drug discounts the rule requires
federally qualified health centers
to give their discounts to the uninsured
it was originally cited to take effect
january 22
but hhs delayed it until march 22nd the
biden team could eventually withdraw the
rule
to prevent it from taking effect at all
so i guess they've
put a hold on it trump was trying to
make sure as people on the left were
demanding universal health care
notably saying insulin and epipens so
trump was like i'm gonna sign this
saying
you can get cheaper drugs joe biden's
like nah you know why
because the pharma pharmaceutical
companies are lining his pocket with
gold that's kind of weird because he was
obama was all about lowering the cost of
drugs he said that
yeah at least he did he said that a lot
it seemed like that was with obama with
uh
the health care plan that obama said
that a lot but trump actually cared
about
the people who actually had to take
insulin and epinephrine
like he actually cared about people who
really really needed this stuff from day
to day
whereas i don't i did not get that vibe
from obama he always
obama always seemed to cater more to the
elites
trump always seemed to actually care
about people who work day-to-day i don't
know maybe i'm crazy
that was really the vibe i got from
trump even though he was like a top-tier
golden toilet type person you know what
i mean yeah well we have to understand
our medical system
is utterly corrupt and incentivizing it
by throwing a whole bunch of government
money at it is not going to solve that
problem
at all it's only going to make it worse
it's a corrupt institution
that takes advantage of people i mean
i've heard horror stories of individuals
going into hospitals and getting
bills that of course will leave them in
debt for the rest of their existence
and their children's existence until
they say i don't have insurance and then
their bills are lowered 10 times what
they were it happened to me yeah
that happened to me yeah it happened to
you it happened to many other people
that i know as well and
and what kind of system do we have when
literally people are preferring to take
ubers
rather than ambulances ambulances for
thousands of dollars
so i i was uh i was at skating uh i'm
chilling
and all of a sudden i got an extreme
pain probably the worst pain i've ever
felt in my abdomen
yep and i was like i fell down like to
my knees like
ah like it was it was it was
mind-blowingly painful
and so it starts to subside a little bit
and i'm like i don't know what this
could be it could be an appendix rupture
i could be like because
i heard when you get a pedaside as you
have like the pain hits and you have
very little time
so i called the cab i called an uber uh
uber pulled up and i went to the
hospital and turns out i had a kidney
stone
is extremely painful and it's when what
people don't realize too because i watch
too many movies
it's traveling from your kidney through
your ureter so it's like an internal
organ
thing from your kidney yeah and that's
why it hurts so i went to the hospital
they didn't know it was wrong they gave
me a ridiculous amount of drugs
and then i it's it stays for a while
like i had to go back uh
you know several days later because that
because it started i started getting hit
by the pain again
and this time they figured it out uh i
ended up getting a bunch of crazy drugs
and then i got the bill in the mail and
it was i think
it was like like 25 thousand dollars for
money for god
yeah yeah some ridiculously high number
and so i called them and i was like this
can't be right
it was like an overnight stay in the
hospital and a prescription and then i
had another overnight stay
and they were like no the bill is
correct and everything you know just
give us your insurance and i was like i
don't have insurance
because it was the week i had just left
vice and before i joined fusion
where i lost for like four days
insurance
and they went oh one second let us send
you the updated bill and it was like
3700. so they were like
oh you don't have insurance then we're
not going to extort your insurance
company
and or they will they do these deals but
i will say with respect to fusion
uh when i told them what happened they
agreed you know they were like don't
worry man we'll take care of you we
don't want you to be put out so they
covered the cost for me well that's cool
that was cool
shout out to fusion
do you know the name of like the i'm not
gonna name any name sounds like cool
dudes i know you had a
tumultuous time there that it was the uh
president of the company
cool the president and the ceo take care
of your employees i was like
you know look i just left vice and i had
insurance and these four days before i
started with you guys i'm apparently not
covered i didn't realize this i thought
it was going to transfer over and
they're like no no no you don't worry
any
at all we got it we'll take care of you
anything i need to do i literally go to
mexico
and they have better service way better
prices
uh and and they take care of you i mean
i had dental work done in the united
states i had it done
in croatia colombia poland way better
service
one-tenth of the cost uh and just every
i mean i remember being in in colombia
literally uh i don't know if i should
get into some of the details here
uh but frog venom injected into your
scars that was mexico
that was mexico that was when i did
combo on my youtube channel and if you
want to see me puke and do other stuff
that are pretty interesting check out
what was the change what was that like
it was intense and it was absolutely
crazy
and yes you could see that type of stuff
on my channel but
and in columbia they literally had these
huge massage chairs right
they had a neck pillow they had collagen
lip masks
they had this desensitizer that they
they put in your mouth
to numb your mouth before they they do
any work that you didn't even feel the
needle it was this like new vibration
technology
that that they like i was like okay
we're going to numb you now they did it
i'm like when are you going
and then they're like we already did i'm
like what this is insane they had a huge
television not you know on the side but
in the ceiling they gave me a remote
they gave me these proper headphones
they had the most beautiful gorgeous
nurses you could ever imagine
oh hey senor can we help you oh you want
something to drink
whatever you want they had an open bar
and and then one tenth of the cost
would work that was absolutely
beautifully done
um in in places like columbia so what is
that is that free market or is it
universal system that's um
that was you know i paid for it yeah um
i i forgot exactly what the
exact system that they have there
because i i've been doing medical
tourism forever
everybody's got universal health care so
well how about that
is there like insurance companies that
will cover you no matter where you go in
the world
well if it's urgent yes but a lot of
insurance companies are scams
so i mean whether it's you know
the the extra insurance you get there's
always little provisions there there's
always little things and there's always
surprises that kind of catch you
literally
you look like you have something to do
yeah so i worked in a hospital for a
while and i really started to think so
the first thing that
luke told me when i told him that i was
sick he's like we're gonna go to mexico
you're crazy and he's like yeah no it's
actually a thing and i was like oh maybe
so because the us healthcare system i
know is an absolute sham
you're absolutely correct and i do think
that the american health insurance
system
really is a scam too because they're a
little bit like the american college
system in that they jack up their prices
to meet
what the insurance company will pay
that's a problem because the insurance
company will pay whatever they ask
exactly and then my insurance i had
insurance right
and they wouldn't cover any of my dental
work and i'm like what do you do what
that why am i paying for insurance
you're not even going to cover my work
literally so happy in colombia
uh beautiful country uh and an
interesting fact about colombia they
actually have this
the the same record amount of cocaine
production like they did in the 80s
but with huge dramatic reductions of
violence so they're trying to make it
tourist friendly
uh and uh and this is where we make the
cocaine yeah
i hear amazing things about it so record
cocaine production
and the most increased of increased
amount of
peace that has that colombia has had in
a very long time so
a lot of amazing history i know a very
beautiful place
i know tons of people yeah like i know
people from the suburbs of chicago who
are like middle class and
you know like yo what up i'm like oh i'm
going to mexico what for vacation oh no
i'm getting dental work done
yeah i know too many people they tell me
that because they're like
the amount of money it costs you to fly
there and then the amount for the dental
work is cheaper than going to a dentist
in america yup see it
sounds like bad american business sounds
like they're outsourcing jobs
and you know maybe that's that's free
trade and we gotta
so it's connected to like the the
education industry that charges insane
rates for a person to go become a
dentist they got to spend six to eight
years or whatever go to medical school
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
for
whether that's even questionable whether
you actually need all that schooling or
if you just need the real world ability
to do it
um i got i got a wisdom tooth pulled by
this dude who i didn't seem like he knew
what he was doing oh geez
anybody probably went to school well he
still didn't really know he's like that
one's in there he took a chisel he's
like
so yeah you can go to school and just
kind of breeze your way through and
still not know what you're doing so it's
weird that all you need is a piece of
paper and then you can officially become
a doctor
um obviously you got to have a real
ability but
you know doctors aren't they don't study
health and fitness necessarily they just
study medicine
um so if you're a do a doctor of
osteopath you
you study everything that somebody needs
to actually like be healthy
if you're an md you study only the
things that are wrong with people which
i can understand being an issue because
people complain about only seeing the
things that are wrong with people
so i think your question might be with
do's or with mds it's
it's such a massive overhaul of the
system that we need to do if we want to
make the medical industry not charge a
million dollars by the insurance
agency which is it's these kids by the
by the balls who are like
dentists and doctors it's not it's not
so easy though because no it's not
you got millions of jobs tied into that
right and overhauling that would mean
terminating those jobs a lot of
parasitic jobs but it's still jobs
right yes that's so weird so they're
like sorry
we it's it's already there sorry it's
damaging you what are we gonna do you
know
i guess the challenge is uh ignorance
and ideology
if you can go and look at how good the
system works in a different country
and then you know a lot of people in
life will try to extrapolate data and
say look we could do it here when the
populations are dramatically different
and the resource availability is very
different
so it's hard to do it's hard to do it's
hard to figure out how we actually
fix this broken system a lot of people
say let the free market decide and it
would solve everything
the left disagrees and they think you've
got to have hard regulation so
we already have hard regulations no no
well so so what they think is
you've got to mix an amalgam of private
and regulation
mashed together in a weird way that
doesn't work properly and i think that's
true
like trying to have a private health
insurance system
but regulated to the point where it
doesn't function properly just gives us
a broken system
so i'm kind of like pick one i don't
care you don't need to pick one and then
we'll start there and try and fix it
that's what's happening in the u.s
because we have like a lot of different
components we're not fully socialized or
not fully capitalistic
it's just a mess and it's a huge problem
for everyone who has to use it which is
like
literally everyone you have to like go
to the doctor at some point you have to
go to the er at some point and every
time it's like a
huge bill on you and it's like what what
a mess
between the insurance company and the
actual hospital yeah get a checkup check
your blood levels yeah
i'd like so we we started this segment
talking about joe biden
and he was rescinding this uh here's the
tweet
mary vaught says biden reversed trump's
executive order to reduce
pricing for insulin and epinephrine
democrats want higher
insulin prices from bloomberg government
well you get what you get when you vote
for joe biden thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you